all right uh yes the draft week one
sunday surprises i'll give you the first
pick since i did that to you even though
i was gonna take the first pick today
because i always give you the first pick
but between you sweeping me in our
head-to-head picks this week and me
doing that to you i'll give you the
first pick okay thank you very much um i
i have a feeling we're gonna have
similar picks or at least when it comes
to surprises i i the first surprise
i you couldn't have told me in a million
years that it would be 23 to six detroit
lions and mitchell trubisky was gonna
bring them back to win a football game
in mitch we trust who needs patrick
mahomes and deshawn watson when you have
mitchell trubisky but no i think that to
me was one of the shocks of the day
offense kind of looked all over the
place again typical bears game like we
saw last year we were just going man i
don't know
what's going on what are they other than
a few plays here and there
but man trubisky down the stretch
finding anthony miller just making a lot
of big throws into tight windows
and they played best with their their
backs you know up against the ball but
certainly played clutch and uh
good for him that should definitely get
the monkey off of his back at least for
a week or two here until we do this
again
yeah and and that was really something
and it's just you know the lions doing
lions things they had the game one late
beyond blowing the lead which is a very
lions thing deandre swift oh my god he
had the ball in his hands in the end
zone and adrian peterson told him after
the game forget about it and move on but
what a way to make your nfl debut that's
never going to go away because that is
the difference between being the hero
and the ultimate goat all in that first
game of your nfl career so i felt bad
for deandre swift he wasn't even
supposed to do much in the month of
september because of a hip injury that
he had so uh deandre hang in there i met
him at the scouting combine while you
were on injured reserve with your uh
whatever it was you puke a lot let's
yeah
but but but but great kid and uh he'll
get through this he'll get over this but
you know it is what it is and you move
on all right for me how about alden
smith oh the guy that peter pegged as
potential defensive player of the year
and i thought peter then you're a little
over the top there 11 tackles two
tackles for loss two quarterback hits
and a sack last night for aldon smith
and this is his first game back in five
years wait until he's in game shape
right and i tweeted last night that
alton smith's performance blows out of
the water the narrative that if you've
been out of football for multiple years
you can't play at a high level and yes
that's exactly who i'm referring to
because that's one of the big narratives
for him five years for all five years
the guy was homeless a year ago he's
playing now he's playing well he's the
guy who had
what was it like 42 sacks in 43 career
games to start his nfl career he has one
sack and one game back and i have a
feeling more sacks are coming for alden
smith good story i love a good story and
i love a good redemption story and he's
in the middle of one yeah it's amazing
it really is i mean it's amazing i don't
i really cannot overstate that
the fact that that guy hasn't played
that long
and then you go on the field sunday
night football and play the los angeles
rams
and really show out to be one of the
better defensive players i mean it was
it's amazing it just shows you what
freak of a what a freak of nature he is
it really is so that that's an awesome
pick by you and i'm glad we got to talk
about that for a second i i think the
next one that just jumps out to me
out of the colts it's not one player or
one thing
but that was shocking yesterday they had
no business losing that football game
i'm pretty sure the colts only punted
one time but it was like i don't maybe
it shouldn't be shocking i don't know
maybe it's not a surprise this is philip
rivers stupid interceptions
you know missed field goal uh what was
it fourth and one inside the five yard
line don't get that there might have
even been another dysfunctional issue i
think i hit them all though but either
way i mean that was a game where they
went up and down the field and really
controlled the football game and just
found ways to screw it up you know and
and and i don't want to take away credit
totally from jacksonville they hung in
there and gardner mint you played really
good football 19-20 how can you you know
really argue with that but
uh wow i just never thought jack the
colts would lose and then i think what's
more surprising to me is the way the
game looked the first 10 minutes of the
game i just went well colts are going to
blow them out yep they're going to blow
them out wait they're losing what it's
tied i mean i was i was shocked by that
yeah and i was gonna pick gardner
minshew i still may depending upon how
many other ideas i have but 19 for 20
and he said after the game this just
shows what we can do that's just a
effing glimpse we ain't even scratching
the effing surface yet but it sounds
like he's been hanging around you yeah
but my camera now this team was 16
rookies on their 53-man roster and dave
caldwell the gm of the team said last
weekend let's give him a chance to play
a couple of games and they go colts
titans to start this season they're not
going to catch the titans by surprise
but they are going to catch the titans
on a short week because the titans play
tonight in the late game and who knows
what this jaguars team can do but 19 of
20 for gardner minshew phillip rivers
looked like the guy who was throwing up
a lot of interceptions last year so i
was stunned by that and i'm glad i
stayed away from colt's giving eight as
one of my best bets of the week i had a
feeling about that when the last feeling
i had though was that the jaguars would
actually win it how about adrian
peterson
93 rushing yards and he added more in
the receiving game a guy this guy do you
bounce around from team to team walk
through the door and almost have 100
yards rushing it's incredible no matter
where he is no matter what's going on
that guy finds his way onto the field he
finds the ball into his hands and he
just keeps going and chris
i
i say this as it relates to frank gore
and adrian peterson as long as a team is
willing to continue to employ them and
give them the football they have a shot
at breaking emmett smith's record
because they're not the ones who are
going to throw in the towel it's got to
be somebody throwing in the towel on
them well yeah you're right well
people are crazy if they throw the throw
in the towel against adrian peterson i
mean he's an nfl running back for sure
you could see again he's got wear and
tear left on his tires he's fine you
know he's he's in a good spot there too
but you know hopefully he doesn't have
to be the bell cow and carry on johnson
and andre swift can you know come in and
help out too but damn it's unreal and he
he's just he's an amazing specimen freak
of nature all of that i just i don't
know why we're shocked really it's like
he's from a different world all right he
just signed a week ago it's amazing it's
alliance i know he signed a week ago
they jammed him into the into the lineup
and he almost had 100 rushing yards yeah
it's amazing to me it is amazing at his
age the wear and tear he's had on his
body i mean it truly is but he's one of
the freakiest and again i'll say i think
he's one of the three greatest running
backs i've ever seen in my life he
certainly will stand out to all my eight
years in the nfl
adrian peterson would be top two or
three people i ever saw in the field
where i went okay we're all pros but
he's on another level that's that's not
a pro that's a different that's an all
pro so whatever all right my last
surprise will be quarterbacks running i
never would have thought quarterbacks
running the way we just saw a week one i
mean i just want to get this right but i
believe we have russell wilson
um course cam newton lamar jackson josh
allen who else am i missing i'm
listening one more who led their team in
rushing
uh yesterday that to me is just shocking
murray kyler murray excuse me right all
those quarterback design runs and
everything like that uh and and lamar
jackson sorry him as well he also led
his team in rushing so that to me is
something i thought we would see
you know the really good quarterbacks
capitalize in the past game i did not
think we would see as much running from
them and especially so much game plan
design runs that was something that
really jumped out to me as i watched the
games yesterday mike
last one for me
no one had a hundred rushing yards at
all yesterday in all those games played
and kyler murray was the closest and he
had a hundred until those two shotgun
formations
got out of there
but
but but what it does it underscores what
clyde edward teller did on thursday
night i think it bodes well for him and
for the chiefs moving forward because
they committed to the run game and the
run game works especially because the
defense is on its heels yeah trying to
avoid getting burned by patrick mahomes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports